[Musique]
huit parlementaires dont cinq présidents
de groupes représentant 226 députés et
sénateurs ont souhaité vous rencontrer
pour examiner avec vous les conditions
de la plus large participation à cet
événement citoyen or à ce jour et par
courrier vous avez refusé de les
recevoir les renvoyant au président du
conseil constitutionnel
cette attitude est inacceptable car
c'est vous qui aurez la responsabilité
technique la responsabilité politique du
bon déroulement de cette consultation
monsieur le ministre s l'excès de
consultations du peuple qui mine nos
institutions ou la remise en cause
systématique des votes et espérance
populaire j'ai transmis immédiatement
votre demande celle des prises en groupe
au président du conseil constitutionnel
pour l'irc évidemment comme je l'aï
indiqué dans mon courrier je me tenais à
sa disposition et en fonction de sa
décision dès lors que le ministère de
l'intérieur agit pour son compte
j'aurais évidemment l'occasion de
préparer et de présenter tous les
documents qu'il sollicitera y compris de
rencontrer les présidents de groupe mais
madame la sénatrice rappeler ce qui est
un bon principe de fonctionnement est
rappelé que le ministère de l'intérieur
n'a pas vocation à court circuiter le
conseil constitutionnel dans la mise en
oeuvre de la bonne consultation
citoyenne sur ce sujet ça n'est
nullement faire insulte à la démarche et
encore moins aux prisons de groupe
madame la sénatrice qui m'ont écrit
sachez madame la sénatrice que avant
même que le conseil constitionnel prenne
sa décision
nous avions préparé les dispositions
techniques pour pouvoir la mettre en
oeuvre sa décision est aujourd'hui
confirmée et nous serons prêts dans le
délai d'un mois pour ouvrir la
consultation pendant le délai neuf
moines et c'est sans merci je vous
remercie
le fichier civique est une procédure
exceptionnelle déclenché en cas d'actes
d'afflux exceptionnel de victimes
il a été détourné de son objet à
l'occasion du mouvement dit des gilet
jaune du seul fait de leur participation
à ce mouvement des personnes ont vu des
informations médicales et nominative
collectées et transmises
alors madame la ministre allez-vous
diligenter une enquête indépendante sur
ces faits allez vous cesser et désavoué
cette collecte d'informations qui ne
respectent pas les conditions posées par
la cnil à la mise en oeuvre de civic je
vous remercie
il ya eu un malentendu pouvoir repérer
les victimes de blessures en marge d'une
manifestation pour adapter le système de
santé ne veut pas dire ficher les gilet
jaune lors des manifestations ont été
activés civis toutes les personnes en
lien avec les manifestations forces de
l'ordre journaliste passant manifestants
ont pu potentiellement être rentré dans
civique sans distinction nous avons
demandé à la direction compétente du
ministère de la santé l ap-hp et aux aux
ars de faire acte de transparence
notamment sur le fonctionnement de civic
c'est une inspection commune de la rs
ile-de-france et de la psp est
diligentée afin d'évaluer s'il ya eu des
dysfonctionnements et s'assurer que ce
fichier sera désormais strictement
constituée d'informations
on ne demande pas à ceux qui sont
susceptibles d'avoir commis l'infraction
de mener l enquête
c'est un principe étonnant quand même en
termes juridiques
par ailleurs le fichier civique a
clairement été dévoyé l'ordre de mettre
des médecins a saisi la cnil mais
malheureusement vous ne respectez pas
l'avis de la cnil comme sur
l'utilisation d'un autre fichier santé
ops site web qui a été croisé avec un
fichier du ministère l'intérieur
madame la ministre les fondements de
notre éthique du soin ne sont pas un
mercato
[Musique]